so David we come to the end of our romp
through the Gospel of Luke and we've
spoken most recently about at the Last
Supper and about Jesus's predictions of
endtime things in got the sense that the
end time was beginning something in the
church and here we come to the the
passion and resurrection and at this
point
Luke overlaps a good deal with Matthew
and Mark but there are some really
distinctive features to both of these
sets of stories let's begin with the
passion all right tell us what what's
distinctive about the way in which well
listen let's start with the very end of
the story of the passion story which is
where Jesus says the last words he says
before his death and in both Matthew and
Mark the last words he says before his
death are my God my God why have you
forsaken me and in Luke's Gospel e says
instead into your hands I commit my
spirit and we've seen how important
spirit is in Luke's Gospel as the
driving force that makes Jesus ministry
possible and we'll make Church possible
and I think we're bound to hear echoes
of that and it's also the case as I
suggested one or two of our sessions
before that I think in important ways
Jesus while he is a great prophet and
while he is Messiah or on his way to
being Messiah he's also a kind of
exemplary faithful person and that when
he says into your hands I commit my
spirit he does what I think he becomes
an example story in a way he does what I
think Luke thinks faithful people are
supposed to do at the time of our death
even our martyrdom which is to commend
our spirits to the God who gave us to
them in the first place and and I see
that and then I'm glad to see where you
go over there I see that particularly in
the way the stories echoed in the story
of Stephen in Acts chapter 7 who becomes
the first explicit Christian murder and
says something very like it Lord Jesus
into your hands I commit my spirit which
seems to me like a kind of
Christocentric echo of exactly what
Jesus says and another example story do
you think Luke is reacting to the way in
which mark tells the story I do I think
I think Mark's story my God my God why
have you forsaken me which when we do
our discussion embark will have a long
discussion on it has been problematic
for Christians from the start it seems
like a terrible
to be Jesus last words even though it's
the first line of Psalm 22
it just it you don't want Christ last
words to be a cry of utter desolation
and I think Luke seeing that says can we
make this a little bit more edifying and
finds in the example of martyrdom a more
edifying thing where Jesus to say it's
possible he had another source it's
possibly there's something else I think
he's reading through marks text he says
oh not that let's do into your hands I
commit my spirit there are other things
that Luke has Jesus say from the cross
well then the two that come to mind
immediately and then you'll flag some I
missed I'm sure one is the whole
dialogue with the two thieves that that
happens only in in in Luke's Gospel we
have the thieves up there beside him in
the other Gospels but in Luke's Gospel
there's this little discussion where one
thing starts kind of do riding him along
with everybody else and the the
so-called Good Thief which has nothing
to do with goodness it has to do with
with penitence and belief says aren't
you ashamed we're under the same
condemnation is he but we just Li great
theme
he unjustly and I think I think that the
thief who's very nearly the last human
being to interact with Jesus before his
death becomes also a kind of exemplar a
kind of paradigm of the repentant person
who in the light of the Cross recognizes
the justice of our condemnation for sin
and the injustice the innocence of Jesus
and then praise Lord remember me when
you come into your kingdom I think I
think he does just what John the Baptist
as told us were supposed to do what
Jesus says we're supposed to do we're
supposed to repent when we repent God
has mercy in Jesus Christ I tell you
this day you'll be with me in paradise
and and the whole Christian stories kind
of acted out in three verses right no I
think that's very telling it certainly
gives us another indication to Luke's
interest in repentance as a major theme
throughout the gospel now what what
about the saying that has put on Jesus
lips at least according to sound which
is in verse 34 Father forgive them for
they do not know what they are doing
yeah
the the trick on that the reason we
smile is that that some early
manuscripts have this text another
manuscripts do not and entire careers
have been built on asking what's most
likely to be the earliest reading not
mine and not yours career as a thank God
but I haven't had kind of tricky
response to that again it's very much
like Stephen Stephen says of his
tormentors forgive them they don't know
what they're doing I don't know how you
saw the textual problem it seems to me
it's a marvelous examination of a Lucan
theme as if Luke didn't say it you
should have because it fits the kind of
claim we've had about Jesus in the
prodigal son and the lost coin and the
lost sheep in the words he's gonna say
at the very end of the story that he is
the one who declares forgiveness to the
outsiders here the outsiders are so far
outside their his own killers and
fermenters and yet the mercy of God
extends far enough even to forgive them
so I preach it and hope Jesus said it or
at least hope Luke wrote it down yeah I
think I agree with you on that one
there's one of the little point that I
want to highlight and that's in verse 47
when the Centurion who saw Jesus his
spirit says something you you said that
the the good thief was one of the last
you know the last right yeah what do you
make of this well the the Greek is
tricky because it says truly this well
let me go back to mark once again at
this at this point in Mark's Gospel and
in a similar bone conduct in Matthew's
not exactly but similar the Centurion
says truly this was God's Son in in this
Gospel he says truly this man was and
then the word is D Caius which can mean
innocent as at the end of a trial or can
mean just righteous righteous that great
theme that goes through much so much
through Paul's writing and maybe
occasionally
in Luke's as well at one at the simplest
possible level but let me come back to
that DKI Center no I just you already
won that when the lawyer comes along
what he wants to do is to righteous
himself mm-hm and now Jesus has been
righteous is this just saying that like
any good martyr this was an innocent man
like Stephen as an innocent man and we
marvel at the fact then he needs
innocence he is nonetheless been killed
or is this somehow as Paul would say the
righteousness of God is this God's right
action for us in I don't know I'd have a
slightly different take on that and not
see it so much under the Paul I know but
under the theme of righteousness in Luke
okay and righteousness in Luke from the
first chapters on and would have to do
awards do this but take my word for it
that right the the the term dia de chaos
and TKO soon a and Luke has to do with
obedience to God and I think they they
Centurion is making a loop in confession
he the truly obedient the truly
righteous one I think innocent is too
thick I think so
that's what I think is it just yeah so
this is one of those places where the
NRSV could be improved yes let's turn to
the resurrection okay and tell us about
the distinctive features of the
resurrection stories and Luke well I
think the the appearance stories are
somewhat different than they are in the
in the other Gospels but the most
striking feature of the Lucan story is
Luke's alone which is the story of the
road to Emmaus and you'll remember that
on that story two disciples are walking
along the road from Jerusalem to Emmaus
bemoaning the fact that Christ has been
crucified and unrecognized third joins
them asked them what they've been
talking about they explain what they've
been talking about this unnamed third
person begins to explain to them why it
was necessary that Jesus should die they
go to the home they invite him in they
break the bread and in the breaking of
the bread
one they recognize him and two they
remember that on the road from Emmaus he
has been opening the two of them the
scripture and as he did so that their
hearts burned within them and I know
it's because I'm a preacher that I think
that this is a text that says for the
Lucan community resurrection continues
to happen when scripture is faithfully
interpreted and where the Lord's Supper
is faithfully celebrated that that that
I'm sure there's a great day coming for
but in many ways for him first day
preaching and celebration of the meal is
the Messianic banquet not just for told
but enacted lived out coming to be yeah
there are certainly different ways in
which Christian traditions have thought
about the the Eucharist and what happens
there all the way from the Catholic real
presence and doctrine of
transubstantiation to you know a highly
symbolic but significant meal and you
know the traditions etc but I think for
Luke there there is a kind of real
presence I do and it's a real presence
in both Scripture and in the Eucharistic
action absolutely and it's interesting
the dining motif here once again Jews
once the consummate which is where it's
the place where Jesus has most often
reached out to invite unlikely people to
the meal it's the place which he
promises will be the sign of the
Messianic age that will be joining the
banquet and now it becomes what church
does not just in remembrance of Christ
but in celebration of Christ's presence
I think it's very very powerful I'm not
very Baptist at that point I don't think
we just remember him fondly mm-hmm I
think at that point we're promised that
he's there and when the word is preached
and the sacrament is celebrated say a
little bit about the way in which the
geographical focus of these stories
differs from that in market and Matthew
yeah in market and Matthew it's very
clear that Jesus predicts that he will
appear to them in Galilee and does so at
the end of mark we only have the
prediction that to go to Galilee Jesus
will be there than the odd ending of
mark which seems to break off
mid-sentence but that's it folks in
Matthew's Gospel we not only have the
prediction but Jesus does appear and
gives the so-called Great Commission go
into all the world and preach the gospel
here Jesus appears in Jerusalem and
promises the spirit that they're to stay
in Jerusalem until the Spirit falls upon
them if we've seen it all along that
Jerusalem the story starts in Jerusalem
Acts will start in Jerusalem Jerusalem
is the place where the continuity and
discontinuity come together where
Jerusalem is Israel's place and now it
becomes the church's place and so it's
both the place of continuation kind of
hinge is the hinge Slim is a hinge and
as the hinge it's the end of Luke in the
beginning of EXO it's a narrative image
yeah I think so too other features I
want to call attention to Jesus appears
one more time at the end of this chapter
yeah after the appearences disciples on
the road to Emmaus yeah and what do you
make of that story in the upper room
well I think I think a couple things
happened one is that he appears again in
their presence that he explains to them
in a way as he did through the disciples
that everything that's happened to him
has been the fulfillment of Scripture
that it was all necessary and then I
think a little bit he does what what
Matthew does in the Great Commission he
sends them out telling them what they're
going to have to what they're going to
have to preach and what they're going to
have to preach are the two great Luke
and themes repentance forgiveness of sin
so they they they are supposed to preach
what the thief has just enacted
repentance and forgiveness of sins what
John said they were going to have to do
and the mercy that's been declared to
him from the beginning so now in some
ways the church takes on the job and
carries it over right so you had the
Declaration of those important gospel
themes and also the reference to the
hinge right this is drew explained in
the knee in his names of all nations
beginning from drinking a ruler to be
witnesses of these things just before
that though Jesus presents himself to
his disciples and tells them to touch
his hand to see that he has real
relations yeah and he asked for
something to eat he does because he
loves to eat he does and he'd live right
this is this is the eating text but yet
in gospel and because I think he he's
Luke is doing what all the Gospels do in
somewhat different ways and which is
very complicated for all of us he wants
to make clear this is not a ghost
this is not an apparition that
resurrection is something that happens
to Jesus not just in the minds of the
disciples and the way you do that is you
show the wounds or you touch the hands
or you eat a meal this is this is the
final act in the mission of Jesus which
is the transition to the life of the
church and its really Jesus not just the
memory of Jesus it's interesting the
balance between the kind of highly
symbolic story of the road to Emmaus and
then the insistence on the the physical
character resurrection of that one last
no
the very end of the gospel is an account
of the Ascension of Jesus which is a
little different from the account of the
essential that we get in the beginning
what do we make of that difference I
have no idea what do you make of that
difference very good question but I
think we have another hinge here okay
and I think the fact that Luke tells the
same story in 20 different forms is
analogous to what's going on in the
juxtaposition of the symbolism and the
physical reality of the Resurrection
that felucca there are always there's
always more than one way there's that's
right and I think we have the same thing
going on here every ascension is a
reality to take place 40 days after the
resurrection or a resurrection eat
immediately right yeah in any case Jesus
is with God and he's also through the
Eucharist in Scripture with us and the
Spirit is the bond of death that's right
thank you